[Music]
the major source of all inflammation in
the body is actually the gut
so your gut hosts the largest number of
immune cells in the body so that you all
you most of the immune cells in your
body are found in your gut you've got
them in your spleen your thymus and
you're obviously in your blood
so in addition to immune cells being in
your gut you also have a lot of bacteria
in your gut
and those bacteria play a very very
important role in regulating your immune
system
so you're talking about people that are
eating unhealthy they're not getting
enough fiber and
you know they're doing damage in the gut
and that's
causing a lot of immune cells to become
active chronically
every day you know you have to feed
those bacteria the right types of foods
you can kind of think of them as little
chemical producing factories actually
because when you feed them
the right type of food which happens to
be fiber
fiber gets digested by this bacteria
in your gut in your colon specifically
and it produces a bunch of different
chemical products called short chain
fatty acids
which are little signaling molecules
that tell
your immune cells in your gut to become
a certain type of immune cell
so they'll tell them okay become this
type of immune cell that
is involved in preventing autoimmune
diseases making sure
your immune system doesn't get so ramped
up that it starts to just
attack everything including your own
organs that's very important
that's dr rhonda patrick and this is a
special deep dive edition
of the ritual podcast
[Music]
the ritual podcast and now for something
a little bit different
after eight years and 500 plus
conversations
i've compiled quite a library of
bankable
timeless information and advice however
because of the way the internet
functions
and or the way the human animal operates
there does seem to be this sense that
content created in the past
is somehow less meaningful than more
currently published content in many ways
this is incorrect and so to rebut this
falsehood
i felt compelled to better organize the
best of our
thousand plus our audio library and over
time
convert it into a more helpful
productive
accessible and hopefully practical
resource for
all of you and one of the several ways
of accomplishing this
involves tapping this archive to create
episodes organized not around a guest
but
instead around a single theme
or subject matter this episode
is an initial experiment in doing just
that the first in what
will be an evolving series of deep dives
beginning
with today's exploration of the
microbiome
courtesy of a collection of gut health
experts that have graced the show in the
past
a couple more things to say about all of
this but first
only a little over a week remains to
take advantage of our new year's
discount on the plant power meal planner
so if you would like unlimited access to
thousands of amazing plant-based recipes
customized to your preferences
if you would also like all of the
groceries to prepare said recipes
automatically delivered to your door
plus tons more awesome features all for
just a dollar fifty a week
then here's the thing you kind of have
to act now at least before midnight
january 31st
by going to meals.richrol.com use promo
code power20 at checkout
and you my friends will save 20 off
in annual membership that's
meals.richrol.com
promo code power20 for 20 off
an annual membership to our plant power
meal planner
while we're at it we're supported today
by calm the app designed to help you
ease stress and get the best sleep of
your life because
as i'm personally always hammering home
solid
shut eye is honestly the easiest and one
of the most effective ways to
improve your overall health and
happiness and calm has a whole library
of programs
specifically designed to enhance healthy
sleep
like soundscapes guided meditations
and over a hundred sleep stories
narrated by soothing voices like stephen
fry
the delightful laura dern and of course
the hypnotic drawl
of mr matthew mcconaughey over 85
million people around the world use calm
to take care of their minds
and to get better sleep to help you
transform the way you sleep
com is offering a special limited time
promotion of forty percent off
a calm premium subscription at com.com
rich roll that's forty percent off
unlimited access to com's entire library
and new content is added every week so
get started today
at calm.com rich roll that's calm.com
slash rich roll we're also brought to
you today by my finnish fungi
friends at four sigmatic for the past
i don't know like six years at this
point
i have been starting my day with either
their cordyceps coffee
which is amazing pre-workout or if i
need to
sit at a desk or stand at a standing
desk and
write or think creatively my go-to is
their ground mushroom coffee with lion's
mane
i love it i love how it gives me focus
how it supports creativity
and i love the even keeled energy boost
without the midday crash
that my friends is the beauty of my
favorite functional mushroom
lion's mane and also i might add chaga
these things keep the caffeine under
control to support clean
focused energy i know what you're
thinking
does this coffee taste like mushrooms of
course it must
right it's made out of mushrooms no it
does not it tastes just like
good coffee period and right now you can
receive
ten percent off your four sigmatic order
now is the perfect time to try four
sigmatics best-selling mushroom coffee
or any of their other delicious products
just go to foursigmatic.com roll or use
promo code roll at checkout that's f o
u r s i g m a t i c dot com slash roll
to receive 10 off your order okay
well i've said this many times before
but because
it is so mind-blowing i think it's worth
repeating
and here it is only about half our cells
are actually human the other half is
comprised of all the bacteria the
viruses
and the fungi that live in or on our
bodies
and we choose to believe nonetheless
that
despite the fact that we're the
symbiotic host
of essentially an entire kingdom of life
that nonetheless we're still fully
sentient and self-governing that we're
entirely responsible for our health our
moods our decisions
but the truth of course is far different
and in fact to a large extent
our emotional state our propensity for
disease
the nature of our cravings and even some
of our decision-making
can be traced back to the nature of our
gut ecology
most of these microorganisms as i said a
moment ago
are symbiotic maintaining a healthy
culture of the right microorganisms is
fundamental
to good health but should the quality of
your microbiome go awry
health havoc is certain to ensue so to
better
understand the vital role these
microorganisms play
in our health and our lives today's show
is intended as a microbiome
master class courtesy of the
gastroenterologists
the scientific researchers and various
gut experts that have graced the show in
the past
the full episodes for whom can be found
in the show notes of course
we begin today with a basic definition
of the microbiome the vital functions
microbes play in regulating our bodies
how antibiotic use can compromise our
gut flora
and in turn our immune systems and the
adverse effects of
over sanitation all of this
is coming to you courtesy of my awesome
friend dr robin shutkin
respected integrative gastroenterologist
microbiome expert
and best-selling author of books that
include gut bliss
and the microbiome solution
so probably the first thing we should do
is define what the microbiome is
so it's basically the trillions of
bacteria that live in and on our bodies
mostly bacteria but also viruses
and protozoa and helmets worms for those
of us who have them
so about 100 trillion in all 100
trillion and how many human
cells are we we are outnumbered ten to
one
by our microbial cells and genes
so it's this crazy thing where we're
really just host
to something that outnumbers us ten to
one it's crazy when you start to think
of it that way
and there's this idea that uh when we
talk about the microbiome we're really
talking about
the gut bacteria but really it applies
to everything that's on our skin and our
hair like you know our biggest organ
obviously our skin right
and the ecosystems really vary
tremendously so even on your skin
the bacteria that live in your
nasolabial folds
close to the nose and mouth are
completely different to the bacteria
that live on your cheekbones a couple
inches away
on the same part of your face so it is
the microbes from the gut to the vaginal
milieu to the lungs to the mouth
to again just a couple inches away on
the skin are all completely different
based on the differences in moisture
and oxygen content and sweat glands and
all sorts of things so
pretty fascinating the different
landscapes and really the idea
is that most of these microorganisms are
not
faux they're a friend or they're kind of
like neutral right
yes exactly and how did you first become
interested in this
so my area of expertise or interest is
inflammatory bowel disease crohn's
disease and ulcerative colitis
and those diseases crohn's which is sort
of the prototypical inflammatory bowel
disease was described by doctors crohn
oppenheimer and ginsburg in the 1930s
at mount sinai hospital where i did my
gi training and
we still you know almost 100 years later
just a little short of 100 years later
we're not really that much closer to
figuring out
what caused these diseases like most
autoimmune diseases the
medical community it's sort of like well
you just have them there's a genetic
predisposition but they're not really
genetic diseases
so i was seeing a lot of these patients
and i like a lot of other
people in this area started noticing
that many of them had this common thread
of frequent antibiotic use so i started
asking and people would say yeah well i
was on a bunch of antibiotics for strep
throat but that was decades ago or i
took
tetracycline for acne in my teens but
what does that have to do with me having
colitis now or crohn's now in my 30s
and then there was an article a
meta-analysis look at a compilation of
many different studies from mount sinai
that came out
and actually showed that antibiotic use
interestingly the two antibiotics that
we use to treat these diseases
were main risk factors for developing
them so
i i just started to have this really
uncomfortable feeling like you know
we're
we're creating disease and not realizing
it
and we really have to let people know i
would see patients coming in and they
tell me they've been on
antibiotics for acne for three or four
years and lo and behold now they were
developing gi symptoms
and there didn't seem to be a really
clear connection between those things
in the minds of the people who were
experiencing it and certainly not in the
minds of the doctors who were
prescribing
and i'd been one of those doctors up
until very recently
so i i felt this very strong
urge to spread the word a little bit
and unlike my first book gupless which
probably 90
of the stuff in the book i knew and was
just my daily experience seeing patients
with gi
problems and very little research the
microbiome solution was sort of the
opposite i learned
so much writing this book i had this
basic idea
that we were on the wrong path that we
again were thinking of our microbes as
foes rather than friends
but i had no idea how much of the wrong
path we were on until i really started
researching it
interesting so let's explain maybe or
explore a little bit about
the function of a healthy microbiome and
what kind of uh
biological functions it helps regulate
and
in terms of like keeping us healthy or
leading us astray from health
so you talked about us being host to the
microbes
if you think of our body as a factory
and all these different things have to
happen the kidneys have to filter
urine the heart has to pump the lungs
have to swap carbon dioxide for oxygen
the digestive tract has to break down
food into its constituent parts of
protein
and fat and carbohydrate and then absorb
them through the lining and carry them
to the different organs for energy
all that stuff has to be done by
something
someone and those some things someone's
are our microbes so they are sort of the
worker bees for the factory that
help all these processes keep running
smoothly
not just in the gut of course that's
where we as you said that's where the
majority of the microbes are but in
all kinds of different areas too so if
we think about something like
energy for cells energy for cells in our
digestive tract kalanasites
what do they use for energy they use
short-chain fatty acids where do the
short-chain fatty acids come from
they're byproducts of the microbes break
them down and provide the shirt
yes exactly um producing vitamins there
are a whole bunch of essential vitamins
that our bodies can't make on their own
that gut bacteria involved in
methylation processes to create these
vitamins they clear toxins from our body
cancer causing toxins some less
aggressive toxins
so they're all these vital functions um
i mean really
you know at its core essentially what
you're saying is sort of maintaining
this healthy gut flora and you know
microbial
ecology that you know propagates all
over your body
is absolutely essential to maximizing
health and
preventing disease etc but this is sort
of at odds with kind of
the last several decades of medicine
and this kind of over sanitization of
not only our environments but
our bodies right and with that i would
assume comes either
in ignorance of the important functions
of the microbiome
or just a sense of it not being
essential or
important is that fair to say that's
absolutely fair
so in the 1950s a researcher from the
london school
of tropical medicine and hygiene named
david strahn was
tasked with trying to figure out why
they were seeing so much eczema and hay
fever which are sort of classic
autoimmune diseases
in post-industrial london everybody had
left the farm for the factory and they
were seeing this sort of epidemic
and he found two really interesting it
was like a 27-year
study looking at thousands of kids and
their families and he found two really
interesting things number one
kids who lived in large households with
lots of siblings had far
fewer lower rates essentially of hay
fever and eczema
because they were sort of being
immunized by their siblings who were
sneezing on them coughing on them
dirting them up in general which we now
know is a good thing
and children who came from more affluent
households where there were higher
standards of hygiene with bathing all
the time washing all the time things
were super clean
had also higher rates of these things so
it was good to be
it was good to be in a large litter if
you will with lots of litter mates
and it was not good to be too wealthy
and too clean
and at that time i'm not suggesting that
people of higher socioeconomic status
are greener in general
but that was a phenomena in
post-industrial london is that
higher socioeconomic households of more
means
had more access to these sort of newer
at the time
hygienic modalities they had more
showers and baths and so on so that was
the beginning that formed the foundation
for something that's called a hygiene
hypothesis
which basically says that our immune
system needs exposure
to germs to bacteria for training so
that it can recognize and distinguish
between friend and foe
and when that doesn't happen as was what
was happening in post-industrial london
when people were starting to be cleaner
is that the immune system gets confused
and then it starts to react to its own
body so
in the case of the diseases i see
crohn's and ulcerative colitis
the body starts to react to the gut
tissue and creates ulcers and
inflammation
right they're autoimmune diseases
autoimmune in the case of arthritis it's
a joint
psoriasis and eczema it's a skin so
there's a direct
correlation between autoimmune diseases
and the level of hygiene and sanitation
as countries get
more industrialized more developed and
the level of sanitation and the use of
things like hand sanitizers and
antibiotics and so on
fluoride chlorine in the water as that
increases
the rate of autoimmune diseases start to
increase and we're seeing this in india
and the middle east
and it's a real problem because again we
have to figure out i mean it's great
chlorination of water helped to
eradicate cholera outbreaks and so on
so it's sort of a tough situation you
don't
want people drinking dirty water and
coming down with outbreaks of cholera
but at the same time with super
sanitizer water now it's full of
chlorine and chemicals
and again it's one of these contributors
to autoimmune disease so there's a
balance there
between being safe and not having
large numbers of people exposed to
potentially harmful microbes
and just super sanitizing everything
increasing right yeah it's like the
the pendulum has swung too far i mean
certainly you want uh
you know a sanitary situation in the
event of like an acute
you know infection right you want you
want like the surgery room
you want the instruments to be you know
very sanitary but we've kind of taken
that idea and run too far with it right
like our purell culture
is out of control and you know the idea
behind that
is oh if you want to not get sick you
want a germ-free environment but
basically it turns out it's the opposite
like that kind of
low-grade continuous exposure to all
sorts of
maybe pathogens is too extreme a word
but just you know the general
environment in which we live
allows our immune system to respond and
kind of you know do its push-ups so that
it's prepared for when the day comes
when you have that kind of overexposure
to something that might make you sick so
that your
system can do what it needs to do that's
exactly right
yeah cool so if we track it through kind
of like
you know the lifespan of a typical
individual starting at you know in utero
so coming through the vaginal canal
being born is extremely important you
get that like
you get covered in all of this you know
these these microorganisms you get a big
gulp of it i suppose as you're born and
when you have a c-section
you're denied that kind of like rite of
passage of being born that kind of coats
you and stuff that you need
to be as sort of based in elementary
about it as possible
that will serve in kind of seeding your
microbiome for
you know better health as you mature and
riccino i went through medical school
and
good places i was at columbia for
medical school residency i trained at
mount sinai i had
never heard this i heard this for the
first time at
center for mind body medicines food as
medicine course and i couldn't believe
it i mean my jaw dropped i was like what
this is an important thing going through
the vaginal canal i thought how could i
mean people that's something that people
are much more aware of now but
what percentage of people get c-sections
it's now almost one in three in the us
and granted some of those are necessary
breech births and the
mothers in distress or the babies in
distress but the vast majority
the vast majority are done because of
convenience and
people don't know ob gyns don't know
when i talk to some of my ob gyn
colleagues about this
they look at me like i have two heads
they're like what
so we again you know most physicians and
most
people one could argue it's slowly
changing think that the cleaner you are
the better and as you said there's some
good times to be clean if you're having
your leg amputated you're having your
appendix out or something
it's good to have a clean environment i
want to rub dirt in the open wound
actually speaking
speaking of rubbing dirt in the open
wound there is a fantastic way to rewild
a baby
who has been born by c-section and
that's just to take a little
gauze swab and soak it and obviously it
doesn't have to be sterile because we're
soaking it in microbes
and just sort of soak up the vaginal
juices of the mother and then wipe the
baby down with it after
to sort of try and approximate passing
through the vaginal canal it's such a
simple
low-tech way of doing it but instead
what do we do you know we yank the
babies out after c-section and then we
sort of sterilize them we wipe them down
with all this bactericidal stuff
so we really have to rethink
what it means to be human and to be
healthy and our relationship with
microbes and
this idea that the cleaner and the more
sterile the more chemicals we have in
our environment the healthier we are
if you go down that road you will end up
in a really bad place as far as your
health is concerned
okay so we got our footing but we can't
talk about the microbiome without
talking about
prebiotics and probiotics right but
what exactly are these and
do any of them actually make a
difference or is this just
all marketing hype well to help cut
through the confusion i sat down with
ara katz
and raja durr the co-founders of
microbiome company
seed
let's define the term probiotic so
probiotics are live microorganisms
which confer a health benefit on the
host
there's a couple of key definitions that
are sub definitions within that the
first is
if it has not been tested in a human
population
for the claim that's being made then it
is not a probiotic so
that means double-blind randomized
placebo-controlled
studies scientifically looking to show
that that organism has a probiotic
effect
one popular trick that we see a lot of
commercial interests and corporations
use
is they'll test a probiotic strain for
one very specific or small
or niche outcome like let's say i don't
know antibiotic associated diarrhea for
example
but then they'll position the product as
if it has
utility for a wide audience preventively
or proactively and
there's just no information to suggest
that so um i think that we
really want to see companies and um and
researchers this isn't even just a
a company's thing this is the term and
in the lexicon is used and thrown around
to basically capture any organism which
could have a benefit or that's
theoretically could have a benefit or
even just anything that's been fermented
that's how broad this category has gone
where all fermented foods are now being
positioned as probiotic too but um or
lysates right like it like in um
in skin care yeah so lysates are
organisms that are
uh heat killed and then ripped open and
just the cell wall is being used and
applied
and those are called probiotic all the
time so it's very very important that
the definition
include the organisms being live being
delivered in the appropriate dosages
and having testing done on the
indication in the population that it's
being marketed to
yeah i mean it goes back again a little
bit to the fact that the
the term itself is used so loosely um
not just on products but also
from a dietary perspective like raja
mentioned like fermented foods and
beverages
a lot of people just say i'll drink a
kombucha and i don't need to take
a probiotic and i think that's partially
just because the term itself has become
so
so diluted meanwhile it's an entire area
of inquiry like
you know in within microbiome science
and i think it's especially important
too because in the future
particularly as we look at areas like
you know fertility
uh the treatment of pathology and
disease the way we're gonna metabolize
chemotherapy the way we're going to
think about vaginal health and
preterm birth in the developing world i
mean probiotics have such
potential to make a huge huge impact
and not just because of their health
impact but also from the affordability
compared to other medications the lack
of side effects compared to other
medications or other complications we
really feel that there's such an
important part of our work it's not just
the science and to create what we
believe are some of the most
sophisticated and effective products
but to really steward the translation of
it and to really be able to call out
you know evangelism over evidence you
know if everyone thinks that every
tortilla chip you can just throw
probiotics on
or your shampoo is just ever you know
just throw some microbes in it's
probiotic
obviously those things are not going to
get taken seriously and
actually as a result you know when we've
seen areas of science where
public perception shapes and hinders
funding and the ability to move some of
these areas forward and so i think that
for us like part of a really big
important part of the mission right so
let's dispel
you know misconceptions around kind of
what the typical
sort of thought pattern is or behaviors
are around like the products that are
currently
so fermented foods definitionally are
very different category than a probiotic
it would be considered a prebiotic
unless it's been shown to modulate the
microbiome it's not even a prebiotic
it is just a fermented food that is the
category and i'll give you an example so
a study was done that did a deep
metagenomic sequencing and a kimchi
product
and of the 900 or so different strains
that were found from
the lots that were tested only four are
believed to have probiotic potential
or were advanced into showing that it
has probiotic potential
i think that a lot of the benefits and
fermented foods come because the
bacteria actually pre-digests a lot of
the components and roughage that for
some people are very difficult to handle
so
and they're fibrous they're fibrous and
they're delicious
so this is not a psa against fermented
foods we think they're great
and certainly been used in ancestral
populations for
the purposes of food preservation for a
very very long time if i didn't have a
refrigerator
my diet would be 70 fermented foods but
the fermentation process itself is
bacterial growth right
are these not like sort of positive
organisms that we want to introduce into
our
biome they don't stay there very long
they don't colonize
in fact i would say more important than
the organisms that are used for
fermentation are
organic acids and fermentation
byproducts and some of those metabolites
that we believe could be used by the
human body to have a health benefit but
these studies are few and far between
and so the research is really really
lacking
and actually the way raj is describing
it is like a really important
distinction just because you were
talking about how to like break this
down for
like the general consumer looking at
probiotics it's really important to
think about that a microbe could be
taken so you could actually consume
bacteria
to have a specific effect that it has
been studied for
which is very different than the way
probiotics are currently marketed which
is this idea that it's good bacteria
that you have some good bacteria but
that you're missing some in your gut and
then you take a probiotic and it puts it
back
which is two very different ways of
thinking about them
but the scientific definition is the
former which is that you consume
bacteria that has been demonstrated to
have an effect on the human body
and that's the difference which is and
the where the marketing is right now is
this notion that you kind of like
restore or put the good stuff back
versus that it has an effect in the body
and that by taking it continuously
because um probiotics are
roger was talking about colonization
which is another good myth to bust
um and that there's a lot of people who
think that a probiotic must colonize in
order to quote unquote
work but in fact probiotics are
transient which means that they do their
work kind of on the road
on their way through your body and so
that's an important distinction
that i think a lot of people kind of
don't understand yeah
what is the impact in your mind of the
decreasing diversity
of our biosphere in general you know
through our soil through the
you know our increasingly toxic
environment the way we
you know raise animals for food etc
all of these things playing into species
extinction you know all the way down to
single cell organisms and
and smaller and the like how does this
play into
gut health and how we think about yeah i
mean well
you know one of the things that we are
looking at from a seed perspective and
we have a division of our company called
seed labs
which is where we start to look at the
way in which microbes
could be a part of the solution so like
honeybees are like a really
awesome example yeah you guys are doing
something amazing yes
um this looks specifically at the impact
um on the honeybee gut of neonicotinoid
pesticides
but on the honeybees i'll let raja can
speak a little bit i'll start by
answering your question
most people here would know or have
heard of this phenomenon called colony
collapse disorder which is for
unexplained reasons in the last 10 years
or so
mass mass communities of honeybees are
just dying off indiscriminately we don't
know why the populations are do we
really not know why
we're starting so that's the hook
the answer is the lead two leading
causes or we
the three leading causes are habitat
loss and habit that doesn't just mean
the wild is being
less wild it means mono plant culture of
plants too
so the streamlining the lack of
diversity that's exactly different
the second is a pathogen called
phallibrew disease it's a nasty pathogen
that kills
honeybee babies in the first three days
of life and the third are neonicotinoid
pesticides which the eu had banned last
year
but the u.s still allows and they're
called because they operate
in the nicotinoid and nicotinic
receptor sites in the brain which
etymologically are related to what's
found in the tobacco plant so much so
that if you put a suspension of water
with glucose and water with
neonicotinoid pesticides honeybees will
pick the pesticide water over
sugar water and that's a completely
crazy finding and so what it does is it
slowly disorients bees
and when it compounds and aggregates in
their bodies they just get so
disoriented that they forget where their
hive is
so this thesis was when these
environmental changes happen
the first thing that changes is the
microbiome and so there's a lot of
sequencing work that was done our chief
scientists and our first seed fellow are
the ones that are leading these field
trials
and we actually found that by
reintroducing
three probiotic organisms back into the
b
gut you can a detoxify neonicotinoid
pesticides before they're absorbed into
the body so it's
it binds and releases these common
pesticides and
dampens or protects the immune response
as a result of it but perhaps more
impressively in
early early b communities um you know so
so bees are becoming something like
japan right now where there's a lot of
old bees but very few young bees
and they dramatically and significantly
protect these young bees from crowding
out this pathogen which
is so powerful that if it's found uh bee
keepers are
supposed to go and burn and scorched
earth the entire hive
um to make sure that it is within days
of its discovery community because it
can spread it can spread very quickly
even one spore
can spread and result in an epidemic and
a neighboring hive so
we published about this the first paper
came out in scientific reports in nature
um using a drosophila model that's a
model organism for honeybee populations
field trials just concluded last year we
made our announcement at the end of last
year and
we patented this but then opened up
royalty free the patented honeybee
farmers around the world
and then we hope at some point this year
to roll out bio patties and bio sprays
that are based off these
species after our uc davis trial
commences and so this is a large scale
field trial in almond farms
which is kicking off in a couple months
right so essentially it's a
probiotic right now it's a patty it's
like almost like it's like a pancake
that you put in the hive yeah okay so
they eat it in the hive and
and that populates their gut flora with
something that
helps them avoid the negative impacts
of these nicotinamide
pesticides and of the foul brew disease
so two out of the three leading causes
of colony collapse
right and just for people that don't
know like paint the picture of
colony collapse disorder you know at its
ultimate
yeah bees are the most efficient
pollinators that have or
ever will be discovered or invented if
we lose
bee populations we lose nearly every
single
blooming crop or fruiting crop
that you find maybe some in small
quantities root vegetables
would persist but a lot of the diversity
that you see from above ground
pollination are virtually gone i mean
models that predict that say that the
supermarket
the fruits and vegetables aisles of the
supermarket be decreased by over 90
if we lost so many bees yeah i mean the
easiest way to say it is whatever you
ate
for breakfast this morning probably
won't be here
and there's also other implications like
cotton for example that have of course
other implications for other industries
and other uses
right so it really broadens the aperture
on
the work that you're doing this is not
just hey you know like
we want to create a probiotic to make
people healthy like it's really
an effort to address the declining
biodiversity of the planet
at large and the implications or the
sort of
applications of this science that you're
developing are really
limitless and i think also the
applications of science that's really
often stays kind of guarded you know in
academic institutions or for many
reasons
often doesn't make its way to humans or
or for other applications
that can be immediately kind of put to
use and to make an impact so
part of kind of the bridge we've built
and very proud of
[Music]
much more to come of course but first
today's episode is brought to you by
public goods
the one stop shop for sustainable high
quality everyday essentials made from
clean ingredients
at an affordable price everything from
coffee to
toilet paper and shampoo all the way to
pet food even public goods is your new
everything store thoughtfully designed
for the conscious consumer
so rather than buying from a bunch of
single product brands public goods
members can buy
all their premium essentials in one
place with one
beautiful streamlined aesthetic these
days
i've been loving they're refillable
shampoo and conditioners they're awesome
and i just appreciate how public goods
ethically sources
and obsessively develops all of their
products to be free of
unhealthy ingredients and harmful
additives knowing what's in your
products and where they come from
is important small changes in the way we
shop can make a big impact on personal
health and the world at large so
let's get on it people right now you can
receive 15
off your first public goods order with
no minimum purchase
they are so confident that you will
absolutely love their products and come
back again
and again that they're essentially
giving you 15 dollars to spend on your
first purchase
you got nothing to lose just go to
publicgoods.com
rich roll or use code richroll at
checkout
that's p u b l i c g double o d
s dot com forward slash rich roll to
receive
15 off your first order
and finally finally we're brought to you
by outer known the makers of
my all-time favorite effortlessly cool
and supremely crafted sustainable
staples
made to last founded by pro surfer
global icon
at this point you know this guy kelly
slater outer known is setting a much
needed new standard in the fashion
industry
making great clothes that don't harm
people or the environment
they actually go to great lengths to
ensure that all of their fibers are
planet friendly
and they only work with the cleanest
factories that pay fair living wages
lately i'm all about their blanket shirt
it's just super
dang cozy i think this thing is going to
last forever
so when it's time for that wardrobe
refresh
i can't recommend more highly going to
sustainable outer knowns collection of
men and women's clothes
this is what's happening now people so
go to outernow.com today and enter my
code
roll at checkout and you'll get 25 off
your full price order
that's outerdone.com
dot o-u-t-e-r-k-n-o-w-n.com and remember
to use my code roll at checkout for 25
percent off
check them out today that's outer known
dot com and don't forget promo code roll
at checkout for 25 off
okay to ease back into all of this
i think it would be good to pull focus
on
the link between how we treat our bodies
what we choose to put into our bodies
and what we absorb
into our bodies and how all of that
impacts our gut
specifically our gut lining
and the permeability of that gut lining
and of course in turn downstream what
all of that means in terms of health
and disease our steward for this corner
of microbial exploration is my friend
and podcast standout favorite
dr zach bush truly one of the most
interesting minds working today to
improve
human and planetary health
the first step is to kind of consider
what is inflammation inflammation is
actually a normal biologic response to
an injury
the immune system lies throughout your
body in different shapes and forms but
some sixty percent of the volume of the
immune system and some eighty percent of
the work done by the immune system is
done in your gut lining
and the concept of the gut is poorly
defined
and poorly understood by the consumer as
well as doctors but it really starts in
your sinuses
it is your barrier system between the
outside world and what you breathe the
outside and world and what you drink
eat etc this membrane is extremely
interesting to look at in its
engineering
it's such an interesting under
engineering event this gut membrane
it is the largest surface area we have
exposure to the outside world
it's two tennis quartz and surface area
versus only the 1.8 meters or so of your
skin
surface area so you've got this massive
surface area and the only
covering of that surface is a
cellophane-like layer of
epithelial cells of the gut and sinuses
in the rest
that is about 50 microns in diameter
which is like one cell
thick right one cell thick which is if
you pluck a human hair and cut that in
half
that's the thickness of your gut
membrane so you have this half a human
hair cellophane layer
that protects you from every bite of
food you eat every chemical that comes
into your food chain etc
so it seems like horrible engineering
but on the flip side it tells us
something about what we're engineered
for
we need to be inherently in contact with
the ecosystem and nature around us
and if we start to tinker and screw with
that nature that membrane is going to
become very vulnerable
and start to leak and our immune system
sits right behind that
there had been some papers coming out in
the mid-2000s in the cancer world that
we're starting to say that the bacteria
in your gut were predicting which
cancers you would get
if you were missing these bacteria you
would get prostate cancer if you had
these bacteria you would get breast
cancer
that was so radically bizarre and out
there for
our current model even to this day as to
how cancer worked
but now you fast forward eight ten years
and now there's tens of thousands of
articles that are showing that
genomically
the bacterial genome is way more
important in determining cancer than the
human genome
and so this reality was hitting and so
in 2012 when we discovered these
chemicals that look a little like
chemotherapy that are made by bacteria
and fungi in the soil
it suddenly closed the loop of oh my
gosh what if the bacteria in our gut is
doing the same thing
what if the bacteria and the fungi are
actually our best source of medicine
for everything and so that's the
direction we were going but as soon as
we put this into petri dishes with
cancer cells and beyond
we suddenly realized no no there's
something way deeper happening with this
information stream coming out of
bacteria and fungi
and it was my chief science officer dr
john gilday he's a phd in genetics and
cell biology and he
was the first to realize that we had put
our finger on the glyphosate toxicity
issue
is that this communication network from
the bacteria and fungi was actually
supporting the protein structure
in our gut lining and so it turns out
that the gut is held together as these
trillions of cells that make up that
cellophane layer by tight junctions
these are velcro like proteins that hold
one microscopic cell to the next to
create this coherent
carpet of two tennis courts and he had
recognized before this in a number of
other labs that started to publish that
glyphosate seemed to increase the
permeability of this membrane
and nobody was really sure why yet that
chemical was never patented as a weed
killer
it's only been patented as an antibiotic
and then it was repatented as an
antiparasite
yeah that was the original purpose of it
correct well it's the mechanism
it's the mechanism they recognized and
so the mechanism of glyphosate is to go
in and block
enzymes in soil bacteria fungi and
plants
and that enzyme pathway is called the
shikimate pathway and it's
important because it makes a number of
the essential amino acids
our bodies are composed of over two
hundred thousand proteins
but we only have twenty thousand genes
we have this pathetically dumb
genome in the sense that a flea has
thirty thousand genes so you're two
thirds as complicated as a flea at the
gene level
which i find reassuring if i can't find
my keys or i'm having a bad day i'm like
hey i'm two-thirds of healthcare as a
flea
what can what are my real expectations
here but the reality is we're very
simple at the genetic level
and yet we make over 200 000 proteins
from a bunch of amino acids there's 26
amino acids that will build those 200
000 proteins
those 26 amino acids are just like the
26 letters of the english alphabet in
the sense that
the vast majority of those are useful
but not critical but the vowels these
eight vowels in our language if you
subtract one of those vowels you can
affect hundreds of thousands of words
the vowels in the amino acid vocabulary
here is
are the essential amino acids which if
you start to tweak any of those nine
you're gonna start to lose tens of
thousands of protein structures in in
their
functionality and in their their unique
form
and so those essential amino acids not
only are they important like the vowels
they also can't be made by the human
body
so those nine have to come from your
food chain somewhere
and it turns out that they are only made
by the bacteria the fungi and the plants
you don't have a shikimate pathway in
your human cells and so these
essential amino acids are blocked
through the shikimay pathway by roundup
and so imagine treating a food chain
with a chemical
that blocks the ability of these plants
to make the building blocks for a
healthy human body
forget about a human it's a dog a cat
any mammal any
complex multicellular biology is going
to depend on these essential amino acids
and we literally in the last 15 years
subtracted out the ability to build
the body because we changed the 26
letters
zach spoke about inflammation but it's
still kind of
an elusive confusing subject matter i
want to better understand it what does
it
mean why is it so important and what is
the difference between
acute inflammation like what happens
when you suffer
a physical injury and chronic
inflammation
which is this persistent state that
can be and often is induced by things
like diet
and lifestyle and on the subject of diet
how exactly does
diet itself affect the gut bacteria and
in turn the immune system and how does
all of this relate to inflammation well
here's the wonderful dr rhonda patrick a
phd in biomedical sciences
and an expert in nutrition metabolism
and aging
to break it all down in understandable
terms
you know i don't think a lot of people
really do understand exactly what
inflammation is so
what inflammation is referring to is
it's a consequence of your immune system
being activated
and once your immune system is activated
they start firing off all these chemical
weapons
that are called inflammatory cytokines
and these inflammatory
cytokines are damaged cells inside your
body damage dna inside your body damaged
pretty much everything inside of your
cells but what's confusing to me about
this
is that essentially inflammation is is
an immune system response
to something wrong in your body right
it's your body's way of saying let's
send the ambulance out to fix whatever's
wrong whether you cut your finger
or you sprained your knee your immune
system gets
activated and mobilized to then kind of
visit that
either localized area or in general if
it's stress related or something like
that i suppose
but the idea behind it is to fix the
problem right so on some level
doesn't it make sense that like some
inflammation is good because it's your
body reacting to a problem
in order to fix it absolutely one of the
major downstream effects of having these
inflammatory
cytokines and molecules being produced
is they recruit
other repair factors it it increases
genes in your body that then start to
repair damage
fix things so it's it's an essential
part of repair and recovery system
however there is a difference between
acute inflammation
and chronic inflammation acute
inflammation would be something like
your four-hour marathon run
you know or your two-hour training
session when you're you know running and
you're causing inflammation there you
know inflammation occurs after intense
exercise
that's good because you the inflammation
signals to various you know genes in
your body that turn on
all these antioxidant genes they turn on
genes that repair muscle damage they
turn on all these good
so it's like a stress response sort of
mechanism where you're turning on all
the good stuff
but you need the bad stuff to turn them
on so it's kind of like here
here's a little little dose of this bad
stuff to turn on the good stuff right so
there's
there's sort of the you know exercise
induced oxidative stress that triggers
the
immune system response versus somebody
who's just smoking cigarettes all day
long
and that's causing some kind of internal
damage in a number of ways that's
creating just a chronic immune system
response that is literally just burning
your engine out right
yeah exactly you know the chronic
smoking or in
actually the major major source of all
inflammation in the body is actually the
gut
so you're talking about people that are
eating unhealthy they're not getting
enough fiber and
you know they're doing damage in the gut
and that's
causing a lot of immune cells to become
active chronically
every day so in your experience what
what are the foods that
create the worst sort of inflammatory
response
well i think it's actually more a lack
of food lack of the good foods than
eating bad foods um because
your gut hosts the largest number of
immune cells in the body so that you all
you most of the immune cells in your
body are found in your gut you've got
them in your spleen your thymus and
you're obviously in your bloodstream
but the largest number of them are
actually in your gut the reason for that
is because
you know your gut is exposed to the
external environment
you know food you eat your gut sees it
and that can be pretty lethal if you get
some bad nasty stuff
so right your immune system has to be
there and ready to react to that right
to make sure that you stay alive along
you know long enough to reproduce and
pass on your genes so in addition to
immune cells being in your gut you also
have a lot of bacteria in your gut
tons and tons of bacteria and i've and
there's people that sort of debate
how money bacteria you know there's 100
trillion i've seen references for and i
haven't dug into like
is it accurate or not i mean it's a lot
it's a lot of freaking bacteria okay
ten times more microorganism than human
rights and people you know this that
just
can't it irks them to hear people say
that and you know
i don't know i've seen references that
show that there are 100 trillion
bacteria cells in your in your colon in
the you know distal part of your gut
um and those bacteria play a very very
important role
in regulating your immune system so
you have to feed those bacteria the
right types of foods
in order for them you can kind of think
of them as little chemical producing
factories actually because when you feed
them
the right type of food which happens to
be fiber
fiber gets digested by this bacteria
in your gut in your colon specifically
and they it produces a bunch of
different chemical products called short
chain fatty acids
which are little signaling molecules
that tell
your immune cells in your gut to become
a certain type of immune cell
so they'll tell them okay become this
type of immune cell
that is involved in preventing
autoimmune diseases making sure
your immune system doesn't get so ramped
up that it starts to just
attack everything including your own
organs that's very important
and the type of immune cell that does
that is called t regulatory cells and t
regulatory cells
become t regulatory cells based on this
bacteria in your gut that are
producing these little products that
tell it to do it
um so you know it's very important that
your gut gets fiber and if you look at
like hunter gatherer societies like in
tanzania
they get around 200 grams of fiber a day
and compared to the typical american
diet which is like maybe 15 grams of
fiber
that's a that's a huge crazy and it's
funny because in our culture
we're all obsessed with protein you know
we're all walking around thinking that
we might be suffering from a protein
deficiency
the truth is almost everyone is
suffering from a fiber deficiency and if
we flip those words around
i think we'd all be better off if people
were like did you get your fiber today
did you get your fiber today i mean we
would be in a different place i am so
with you on that is my new motto did you
get your fiber today because it is so
incredibly important and what a good way
to think about it for
for some people that don't really have a
you know grasp on
why fiber is so important when you eat
protein when you eat you know fat
when you're when you're eating these
other sources of energy
even carbohydrates that are not fiber
that you know like refined carbohydrates
that don't have fiber
those things all get metabolized in the
upper part of your intestine they don't
make it to the colon where all
your bacteria are probiotic bacteria
good bacteria
the commensal bacteria that are
regulating the immune system like i just
mentioned
so what happens is because you're
getting protein and fat and refined
carbs
those bacteria start to get hungry
oh what am i going to eat i don't get
the protein i don't get the fat
so they actually start to eat what's
called mucin
which is what it's essentially
the gut barrier the gut barrier is made
of something called mucin and it's mucin
because it's kind of mucusy
kind of slippery and it separates the
immune cells from the bacteria in your
gut
separates the food you know from from
you know the internal part of your gut
so the gut barrier starts to get broken
down
by your own probiotic bacteria that are
good for you because they're hungry
because you've been starving them of
fiber right they're so far down the
conveyor belt that they
they have they're forced to basically
cannibalize themselves exactly and
is that what causes leaky gut and all
these sorts of issues where people are
having all these
you know digestive disorders yes it
causes
a plethora of disorders you know leaky
gut it
affects your immune system because now
your immune system's all out of whack
your gut barrier starts to break down
the immune cells start to see the
bacteria
what do immune cells do when they see
bacteria they fire away they're going to
fire all that chemical warfare i was
talking about it creates more
inflammation
you start to release you know these
things into your bloodstream
causes activation of you know immune
cells in your bloodstream that can
affect your cholesterol and
you know the the lack of fiber it's it's
kind of like i think it's like
this insidious kind of damage that
people just
they don't realize that it's like oh
they may notice they may be constipated
a little or
you know it's just but they don't
realize to what
magnitude this sort of effect can have
when it starts to compound
over the years because it's really
changing your immune system it's causing
inflammation it's aging you it's going
to accelerate the way you age
on every level and you know it can lead
to these diseases these autoimmune
related diseases these diseases of aging
you know all sorts of problems start to
happen and
i really think that you nailed it when
there's a simple solution that simple
solution is
you need to focus on getting fiber i
mean i actually
that is my main obsession i it's fiber
and then i supplement some protein and
fat and all that with
right fiber fiber's at the top of the
food pyramid is the top
that's so interesting and it's all
different types of fiber
because you've you've got you know seeds
legumes you have
oats vegetables fruits you know
they all have different types of fiber
and what we're learning
is that um there are different
types of fiber that are having different
effects
you know so they're feeding different
types of bacteria and they're producing
those bacteria are producing different
types of chemical byproducts which then
do x y or z you know so i mentioned the
t regulatory cells which are important
for preventing autoimmune disease
they also make something called natural
t-killer cells which are
the most important type of immune cell
that kills cancer cells in your body
when we're constantly getting little
cancer cells that arise and our immune
system takes care of it right
it's when our it's sort of like a levels
number you know when
when we get more cancer cells than our
immune system can handle
a because our immune system is weak
because we're not making enough natural
t killer cells or something like that
then then it starts to get to the point
where the cancer cells start to survive
they make it gotcha all right good so
let's get back to
inflammation in general so we kind of
have a working understanding of
inflammation now and
what in your opinion are the leading
kind of causes of inflammation and what
are the ways that we can
you know avoid these like what are some
daily habits that we can
kind of undercut this chronic immune
response that is
making us sick so as i mentioned i i
think
one of the major drivers of inflammation
is gut health
and lack of fiber that's that's really
one of the major things so making sure
you're eating enough vegetables
you know getting getting enough you know
nuts seeds
plants legumes like i think that's i
think that's very very important
for controlling inflammation and that's
been i mean it's been shown that the gut
is the major
regulator of inflammation so that's
number one that's easy
you know increase your intake of
vegetables um
the other easy actionable
for controlling inflammation is believe
it or not actually
causing acute inflammation through
exercise
because it is a
hormone hormetic it's called a hermetic
type of stress where you're inducing
stress
you're then activating all these
anti-inflammatory genes and this has
been shown like
about an hour after exercise
you have a really high elevation of
these pro-inflammatory
mediators and then immediately after
that
like couple hours later is a very strong
anti-inflammatory response so exercise
is a really good way to boost the
anti-inflammatory
processes the natural ones in your body
right so it's like push-ups for your
immune system as well as for your
muscles exactly it really is
it really is um and the other one that
i've really been obsessed with recently
is um curcumin
and curcumin is one of the cucurmanoids
that is found in turmeric right it's a
root
it's a root and what is the difference
between that and turmeric
well turmeric has many different
curcuminoids
in them including curcumin i like to get
no i mentioned the curcumin specifically
because the curcumin is a very very
potent
anti-inflammatory but it doesn't work
the way people may be thinking
nsaids or you know anti-inflammatory
drugs
it works very differently um because
it's actually
kind of like exercise it's a hormetic
stress it's
exact it's actually slightly toxic to us
and because it's slightly toxic to us
it turns on all these really potent
anti-inflammatory genes and it inhibits
the the pro-inflammatory ones as well so
curcumin
is really really good at doing that but
i wanted to differentiate the difference
between
curcumin and turmeric is also very good
because it's the source of curcumin
curcumin's
not as concentrated if you're taking the
full tumeric
which you can buy you know you can buy
the root and have it fresh or you can
buy powder and cook with it you know
curries and stuff or often have turmeric
in it
or you can make tea you can do lots of
things with it but
what's really cool about turmeric is
that in addition to curcumin it has
something in it called aromatic tumerone
which is another curcuminoid that has a
completely different function than
curcumin the aromatic tumerone has been
shown in studies to
actually in the brain increase
neural stem cells so stem cells
in the brain to make more neurons so it
actually increases
neural stem cells to what's called
differentiate which just means these
stem cells become neurons
so it increased dramatically increase
the number of neurons in
little mice brains right so back to
inflammation
so here we have increase your fiber
we have uh exercise we have curcumin
yes and then beyond that let's talk
about
sleep and other stress reduction um
techniques like meditation
and the impact of that on reducing
chronic inflammation
i was just going there yes well it
what's
i've become sort of obsessed recently
with
circadian rhythm or your biological
clock which is related to sleep
you know we're on humans or on a you
know a 24-hour
light or day night dark cycle where
we're
in the day when it's light out we're
active you know we're working we're
exercising we're thinking we're you know
metabolically active and at night
when it's dark typically we're you know
resting sleeping
it's when we're repairing a lot of
damage things like that but what is so
interesting is that bright light
exposure
early bright light exposure is so
incredibly important for
setting your biological clock it's like
an anchor to set it so that it
it knows okay this is days when day
starts
and so this internal clock that you have
regulates
20 like 20 percent 15-20 percent of your
entire genome
many of those genes are involved in
metabolism inflammation that's
true tons and i mean it's completely
regulated on just
when you know the amount of light you're
exposed to when you're exposed to it and
when it's dark it's like this clock and
so um
recently i came across a study that
showed
when humans were exposed to really
really bright light
it was 10 000 lux which is like the sun
when they're exposed to it starting
early for about seven hours
that was able to reduce cortisol levels
which is a
stress hormone cortisol by up to 25
during the next day during its peak
phase
wow 25 so cortisol so translation you
need to be outside and exposed to the
sun
you need you need to be exposed to light
yes that's the translation and
you know just cortisol is it causes
massive inflammation it's one of those
stress hormones that activates almost
every
gene in the body that increases your
immune cells to go fire fire fire
cortisol does that i mean there's a
reason it does that it's a stress
response but
if you are not being exposed to bright
light
because you live somewhere and it's dark
in your house or your apartment or
you work a job where you know you're
just not able to be exposed to the light
it really can have detrimental effects
on health
and you know we're talking about
inflammation here that's at the
at the molecular level that's what's
going on but it you know it has
a lot of effects on your ability to lose
weight to gain muscle mass
your mood brain function memory learning
you know all these things i mean
tons and tons of studies have shown you
know cortisol
you know decreases muscle mass it
actually causes your muscles to atrophy
it causes your brain to atrophy and this
has all been shown experimentally
wow that's amazing so for the average
person though they're not most people
are not able to be out in direct
sunlight for seven hours a day
right so is there like a a manageable
solution for the average person well i
do know
that in terms of just setting the
biological clock
being exposed to seven hours a day that
specifically was referring to the 25
reduction in cortisol um but but just
being exposed to bright light for
like one to two hours uh is
is enough to set your biological clock
correctly
so that your metabolism is going the way
it's supposed to your inflammation's
going the way it's designed
you know you're able to break down fat
you're able to
build muscle mass you're able to you
know repair damage all these things are
being regulated by that
biological clock so that one to two
hours
is key for that which is like sort of
like the minimal effect right right it's
such a crazy thing
that the circadian rhythm is like even
exist i mean we walk around thinking
that we've mastered nature
you know and we forget that we're just
primal creatures
you know living in this basically in the
wild and that we're still
you know we still have to fall prey to
these
things beyond our control
okay got it but how do things like
stress and anxiety play into all of this
for example
is the trauma of this pandemic impacting
our microbiome and in closing
what exactly is the best dietary
approach to optimizing the microbiome
and microbiome health
hint think plant diversity
to close out today's deep dive let's
hear from my buddy dr will bolsoewitz
allotted gastroenterologist gut health
guru
and author of the must read fiber fueled
so many things to talk about i think an
interesting
launching off point for this would be to
kind of contextualize your work with
what's going on
currently in this pandemic era that
we're all
navigating through and what i've been
thinking about lately and i'm interested
in your thoughts on
is how we square this
you know need to socially distance
and sanitize our environments
and kind of cloister ourselves from
other human beings and restrict our
exposure to
a variety of environments with this
paramount need to increase our
biodiversity not just
with the foods that we're eating but
with the
environments that we visit and the
people that we interact with like these
two things are at odds this importance
of biodiversity
maximizing that with this need to kind
of over
cleanse everything at the moment
yeah i i feel like gut health has never
been
as important as it is right now
there is a direct connection between
your gut microbiome and the strength of
your immune system
[Music]
and for that reason it becomes
imperative
that we take care and nurture a healthy
gut microbiome and
the thing that sort of stands out to me
rich is
yes like excessive cleanliness
sterilizing our environment
not being allowed to socialize and
connect with other humans like all those
things are there but to me
the most powerful influence is the
stress
the stress is something that is
affecting all of us i mean it
we are living through a moment of
collective
stress we're all forced to take this on
there's no avoiding it
and that actually has an impact
on our gut microbiome and it drives us
to this place
where we all sort of have different ways
that we cope and deal with that stress
and for many it's to turn to unhealthy
habits
and that includes unhealthy food and
in many cases alcohol and we're
compounding that stress
and we're actually compounding the harm
that it does to our gut microbiome
you know many people when we think about
gut health we talk about food and like
my book
discusses food in great detail
the part of the book that i really
wanted to elaborate on and there just
weren't enough pages for me to go there
is the effect of trauma
the most challenging patients that i see
as a gastroenterologist
are the people who have been victims of
physical emotional sexual psychological
trauma
and it changes them
and they don't realize the way that it
affects their gut
and typically when they get to me i'm
the fifth or sixth doctor
gastroenterologist that they've been to
they're looking for solutions
related to their gut microbiome or to
their digestive issues
and what i discover after getting to
know them and building that trust
and that relationship is that the
solution the path
is actually not through food more so
it's actually about healing that trauma
that is eating at them on a subconscious
level
and all of us are dealing with trauma
right now
and i feel like collectively this is
affecting our gut microbiome
and it's at the worst possible time
there's a direct line between gut health
and our immune system 70
of our immune system lives in our gut
and when we have that
you know that emotional trauma that's
affecting our gut and then
we also compound that by consuming
alcohol or
by eating junk food we are putting
ourselves into a vulnerable place where
if we do get the virus
we don't have our defense system built
up to protect us
and that's the scary thing because
increasingly we're seeing studies rich
that are making connections between the
gut microbiome
and severe manifestations of covid19
where you know the doctors are all
asking the question who are these people
they get clovid19
and one of the first things that we
discovered is it's the people who are
that have diabetes and high blood
pressure and coronary artery disease and
are overweight
and then when you think about all of
those things that i just mentioned
diabetes heart disease
high blood pressure being overweight
they're all connected back to the
microbiome
so essentially to ignore gut health
or to not have a optimally functioning
microbiome
is to put yourself at peril in terms of
your immune response
to covet or anything i feel like this
connection
is critically important in the 21st
century period
i mean look at the explosion of
immune-mediated disease states you know
look at
celiac disease up 500 percent in the
last 50 years
look at inflammatory bowel disease
that's absolutely exploding
and you know there's conditions rich
that when i was a kid literally didn't
exist
that i'm diagnosing sometimes twice in
the same day that are immune mediated
you know things like eosinophilic
esophagitis
and so independent of kovid i feel like
recognizing this connection is really
critically important because the problem
is once you trip that wire once you
cross that line
you may find yourself with one of these
conditions that i don't believe that
there's necessarily a cure i think you
can put yourself into remission
but once you have one of these
conditions i think that you have it
and it's there in terms of
the protocols that we should all be
undertaking to
you know buttress our microbiome you're
not necessarily
advising a specific type of diet other
than to say
plant diversity is king like this is the
vector
of all vectors for you right so it's not
about
oh it's vegan or i mean it's a
predominantly plant-based or plant-based
diet but
the diversity of plants is really what's
important
in terms of making sure that you're
doing everything you can
right in the interest of your microbiome
well i think the critical piece to me so
you know the book is called fiber fueled
and that's because i feel like fiber has
been this
ignored superfood and part of it is that
we've been thinking about it as this
orange drink that grandma stirs up so
that she can poop
when in fact it's incredible the
connection between fiber and our gut
microbiome
you know fiber doesn't just go in the
mouth and shoot out the other end
soluble fiber is a specific sort of
general category
which feeds the microbiome this is their
preferred food
when we give this to them they consume
it
they grow stronger our microbes actually
multiply grow stronger
and then they turn around and they
reward us
and the way that they reward us is by
releasing short chain fatty acids
and these short chain fatty acids have
healing effects
throughout the entire body so you know
we've been emphasizing a little bit the
immune system
short chain fatty acids optimize our
there are studies that we could talk
about if you want to connecting short
chain fatty acids
in terms of protection from respiratory
viruses
they can have their effect in the lungs
on the immune system
short-chain fatty acids reverse leaky
gut
you know which is i mean dysbiosis that
is the root cause of these digestive
issues that i take care of on a daily
basis
they directly prevent colon cancer they
lower our cholesterol they prevent
and reverse insulin resistance which is
type 2 diabetes
they travel throughout the entire body
having their healing effects we think
that they can actually reverse coronary
artery disease
we think that they can actually repair
the blood-brain barrier for people that
have brain fog
they actually travel into the brain
through the blood-brain barrier
and they have their effect they affect
our mood our memory
they affect um they i mean believe it or
not we have
studies that suggest that they prevent
alzheimer's disease
these are incredibly powerful
and the way that you get them is through
the consumption of fiber in your diet
and here's the problem 97 of americans
are not getting an adequate amount of
fiber in their diet
and that's creating issues for us
everybody's worried about their protein
intake
but they don't give a second thought to
their fiber intake
97 of people are fiber deficient
i mean that's a shocking statistic you
know and that's well and that's with the
bose standards i mean the expectation or
the standard that we're holding is 25
grams for women and 38 grams for men
and the average american is somewhere in
the 15 to 18 gram range
and you know rich let me ask you a
question i'm just curious so you i know
you eat a very healthy diet
if you had to estimate in a given week
how many plants
do you think you have in your diet give
me a general idea
i mean it's going to be higher than most
but it can't be more than
i mean 30 40. okay
and i would challenge the people
listening at home right now
like if you have to hit the pause button
take a minute and think about how many
plants you actually have in your in your
diet
okay so most americans are definitely
less than 30.
the majority are around 15 to 20.
there are literally 300 000 edible
plants on the planet the problem is that
we've narrowed it down to the point
where 75 of our diet is from three of
them
you know and we're ignoring this
diversity you know we've put pressure
unfortunately on our farmers
where the farmer has no choice but to
opt for high-yield
breeds of crops we are narrowing down
the biodiversity within our diet through
our food systems right
if there's only one thing that you take
away from this podcast listening to us
have this conversation today this is
what i want you guys to hear okay
the way that it works is this fiber is
not just fiber
there are millions if not billions of
types of fiber in nature
it's so incredibly complicated from a
chemistry perspective
that we're not even capable of creating
an estimate to how many types of fiber
there are
but every single plant has its own
unique types of fiber multiple different
types within that plant
every single plant is going to have
prebiotic fiber that feeds the
microbiome
this is their preferred food these
prebiotic fibers
and the key is that they are picky
eaters
they're like us you have different food
preferences than i do
even though i'm sure that many people
would label us as having the same diet
you eat differently than i do we have
our own preferences
and they do too they have specific food
preferences
in terms of the different types of fiber
you know to put in perspective
take a black bean you give these
microbes a black bean
and there are certain specific species
that are going to multiply and thrive
and they are going to be stronger
and be more prepared to help you because
you just fed them they are energized
but the opposite is true you take that
black bean away you say
i'm going black bean free those same
microbes that were thriving because you
were feeding them
are starving right and they're not
getting what they need and so
the point is we want as much diversity
as possible
and that's the critical piece eating as
many different things as possible
and getting out of your comfort zone a
little bit and the i think the
what you're saying essentially is that
the more that you're in the in the
practice of doing that
it's almost like an insurance policy
that you're taking out for
your gut health you're seeding your gut
with the
the biota that will then ultimately be
able to
grow and thrive the more that you're
feeding it those types of plants
yeah every single plant has its own
unique types of fiber
that's what i've been talking about for
the last few minutes
but there's so much more every single
plant has vitamins
minerals phytochemicals these are the
unique
chemicals that you will find in plant
foods
exclusive to plant foods that's what
phyto means
there's at least a thousand of them very
few of them have we actually studied
an example of one is resveratrol so you
hear about resveratrol you know
it's resveratrol
is capable of actually changing the
microbiome by itself
you know david sinclair in lifespan
talks about resveratrol and its benefits
for healthy aging
and this is just one example of one
phytochemical that you'll find in these
plants
and the other thing by the way that's
kind of interesting most people don't
realize this
the plants have a microbiome of their
own
every single life on this planet
either has a microbiome or is a part of
the microbiome
and depending on how you choose to zoom
out you could almost make the argument
that us humans are part of a larger
microbiome in a way
right which is planetary health and the
way that it all functions
but these plants have their own
microbiome if you take an apple for
example because we have a study that
shows this
you know the apple has a microbiome that
is there
from the seed from like literally the
seed
through the flour and all the way
through to the fruit
and that microbiome is dynamically
evolving
and changing and helping this to
actually this transformational process
to occur
and the apple has literally over a
thousand species of microbes more than
us humans do
and potentially a hundred million
microbes when you eat an apple you're
getting the fiber you're getting the
phytochemicals of which there are many
you get the vitamins and the minerals
and you're even getting
the microbiome that the apple contains
wow
and so each plant
has a story like that each plant
has something positive that it wants to
bring
to your health every single one wants to
bring something to your health
yeah and and what's interesting about
the work that you do
is that it's not about reducing certain
things you're talking about what you're
building it like what you're at it's
very additive
like this whole diversification of your
diet is about
building new things into your diet as
opposed to focusing on what we're
removing i feel like it's easily
applicable
but conceptually extremely sound like
from my perspective
50 years from now this is still going to
be the best way to eat
to consume a broad variety of plants to
be as
predominantly plant-based as possible
you know and
i wrote the book rich to meet people
where they are
so you know when you say well you're not
rigidly inherent to any particular diet
i want people to be 90 to 100
plant-based
that's what we find in the blue zones
that's what i think from a nutritional
perspective is the highest quality diet
and i do think that when people get to
be 90 plant-based they're going to feel
so good they're going to want to keep
going
but i also think that there's an
argument that goes beyond
nutrition and talks about the health of
our planet
and talks about you know the compassion
for these animals
and i think that those should be a part
of the conversation
even if they are not directly human
nutrition i think that kova 19 has
taught us that when we abuse this planet
we may abuse these animals i kind of
feel like it's going to fight back
it's beautifully put and that just
speaks to the inner relationship
of everything you can't talk about the
microbiome without
referencing the macrobiome the health of
our gut is related to the health of the
planet and vice versa
the soil health connects to human health
you know the health of our soil which is
the source of our nutrients
is critically important to human
populations moving forward
i have children and i am scared of what
this planet looks like a hundred years
from now when you consider what it looks
like today
compared to 1920. and
the reality is that we need to just look
at population
right now we have 7 billion people
in 2050 we will have 10 billion people
consider that in 1900 there were only 2
billion people
consider that in 1800 there was only one
billion
people we're going to have 10 times the
population in 250
years and that's putting a strain on the
environment
on our planet on a strain on these
animals
biodiversity is the word it's critical
to our gut health
it's critical to planetary health and it
needs to be upheld
[Music]
thanks for listening everybody hope you
enjoyed this first and what we are
planning will be
a series of topic-specific deep dives
that
we intend to drip out over the course of
the coming year
as i mentioned in the introduction links
to the full episodes for today's
featured guest can be found in the show
notes on the episode page at
richroll.com
if you would like to support the podcast
the easiest and most impactful thing you
can do is to subscribe to the show
on apple podcast spotify and youtube
sharing the show or your favorite
episode with friends or on social media
is of course always appreciated that's
amazing
and finally for podcast updates special
offers on books
the meal planner and other subjects
subscribe to our newsletter which you
can find on the footer of any page
at ritual.com today's show was produced
and engineered by jason camiolo
the video edition of the podcast was
created by blake curtis
portraits by ally rogers davy greenberg
and leia marasovic
graphic elements courtesy of jessica
miranda copywriting by georgia whaley
and our theme music was created by tyler
piatt trapper piatt
and harry mathis appreciate the love
love the support
thank you for listening be back here
soon
[Music]
peace
so
you